[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master
dennis borosch and we are live
on twitch on youtube on tick tock
on instagram and whatever else is out
there i
i can't keep track of all these things
all that said yes i am boros
i am the biggest rival of one punch man
well no
anyways today i felt like looking at
some keras and games
where keras goes toe-to-toe with fisher
you know fisher from brooklyn the
american world champion right now that
wasn't always the case
and a lot of candidates tournaments they
faced off
what about facebook probably that too i
have to
ask but i'm i'm pretty sure everywhere
worldwide everywhere we are live anyways
the first game is between fisher playing
the white pieces
and paul karas playing the black pieces
so let's start from the beginning all
right
so e4
knight f3 knight c6 bishop b5 not a big
surprise at those times as paul cares
was a classical player
not always classical when he was playing
white he would sacrifice
anything and everything that he could
see not quite the level of mihal tal
but he was always a very aggressive
player playing
interesting openings and rare ideas
that you don't even see now sometimes
you'd even consider
saying oh but ah but these recent
streamers
had an idea what an outstanding
combination what an
outstanding pawn sacrifice guess who was
there
paul carris volcarus was everywhere he
was
one of the first superheroes of the 50s
60s
and 70s as yasser
would tell you so let's
speed through the beginning because we
are more interested in the end game part
h3 this is the main move trying to stop
any sort of bishop g4 ideas which could
be kind of
annoying so h3 not a5
queen c2 knight d2 interestingly enough
just so some of you will remember knight
d7
was actually the original invention of
paul karas and now it is called
the keras variation queen c7
knight d2 take stakes should be seven
knight f1
yep these we are not interested in
and we are going to start over from here
now fischer's position is not at all bad
in fact black has more pawn
weaknesses well g7 is not really upon
weakness yet
but that knight on f5 is kind of
dangerous and um just before we
sort of get into the end game part
we can start off with a tactical problem
so this is the first moment we're going
to take a little bit of a pit stop
and try to find bobby fischer's next
move
by the way whenever you're looking for a
tactical idea
you always got to look for loose pieces
because those are telltales and signs
that there is something wrong
with our opponent's position and in this
case paul kerris's position
so even though black has that extra pawn
most of his pieces are a bit scattered
and that bishop is sort of
even though it's attacking the e4 pawn
it's still
kind of passive
so queen g4 would make a lot of sense
however it doesn't force
matters too much and fisher if you know
fisher just a little bit you know
he likes matters if they are forcing
knight h6 check indeed going
for the immediate tactical idea now if
king h hit this knight takes f7
and white wins the pawn maybe even do
a little bit of a bullseye repeating
back and forth
but of course keras is not going to do
that
so instead he goes g takes h6 queen g4
check
that's kind of the main point the king
and the knight
is double attacked the same time king h8
and takes d7 and now the situation is
sort of changing
um white has a little better
pawn structure but down a pawn and of
course
if you have a choice you'd rather not be
with all these terrible pawns that are
doubled
on the d and on the h files
ship d5 in f5
rook e5 queen f3 f5
ship f4 rook e8
all right so again critical moment
critical moment we're not in the endgame
yet
but we're closing in
and just look at how admirably keras
fights
there are multiple pins on the e
file we could take multiple ways but all
of them would lose
for white however fischer decides
to sidestep these
terrible terrible threats
question is how can we do that
if you want to go unscathed that is
usually people don't appreciate how good
keras was
among the bests that is true
keras is one of the best players who
didn't become a world champion
but even that said
he finished second in candidates
tournaments
more than i could count on my fingers
and that means that
his been one of the best players for
decades
which only were champions can say really
like all these world champions
tall smiths love they come and go kara
stayed
he never actually managed to get to play
a world championship
match but he was always tied for second
and getting very close to qualifying
which the others
couldn't say
or branch time
queen h5 indeed and it's a beautiful
move
by fischer you can't take with the pawn
because if queen takes d5 and not only
you're down a
piece but you're losing everything else
as well
so bishop takes c4 is forced
f3 very beautiful tactical play
by fischer there's no bishop takes f3
because of queen takes c8
and you're losing the rook and the game
so bishop c6 but now here comes the big
question
should we trade off as
fisher or should we stay on track
castle is one of the strongest players
never to become a world champion
that is true um however
korchnoy is also someone who
tried multiple times and was dominating
for quite a while so he's
also quite a strong candidate for
the strongest player who never became a
world champion although i'd
still say charis is probably the
strongest one
well chess is a simple game you just
count pawns and if you realize
well we are down a couple and we should
just shouldn't exchange
so fischer decided to go rook c1 instead
ship d7 and the pick pocket
that pawn on h6 rookie 6
take sticks queen h4 print f6
and this is the big
dilemma you'll never guess
what fisher played here not even
if you read the title of this stream
lesson tick tock or
ted talk
who knows who knows which one is the
right answer here
it's a complete riddle
thanks wow
you guys are on fire how could you guess
queen takes f6
unbelievable unbelievable
rook takes f6 okay so
we managed to exchange queens which is a
great news because this is insane in the
end game
but your opponent will not resign
just because you exchanged and you say
well hey i
am the title character you are supposed
to
just lay down and say okay it's game
over
just let's everyone just move on there's
nothing to see here
you still have to work around it right
so task one is done
um the main character the protagonist
showed up
but still have to come up with a plan
i wonder what that plan will be
so i do have a secret formula that i use
when i play chess i count pieces
i know it's rare and it's not something
people
talk about too much because it's
apparent
are we good with the pawn count
or could we actually improve upon that
yes no maybe or you need
an extra hand to count i mean i have
some extra hands if you need one i can
okay so one two three
four five yeah five for
white i'm not gonna help with the other
one i assume all of you
have hands there
yesterday would improve it probably i
think so too
but there's nothing that yasir wouldn't
improve
okay so before we make a decision
let's give ourselves some candidate
moves
i mean i i see that all of you are fans
of these grim tales and little piggies
which kind of weird weirds me out a
little bit like
why why are you guys such a big fan
of those german folktales they're
betters out there
better ones especially stories about
merlin
highly highly advise you to read stories
about merlin
it would actually help you become a
better chess player
okay so we've got rook d1 is an option
perfect and of course
one little piggy could go to c7
but is there a third option
as we all know the third little piggy is
the one who ruins all the fun
or at least in jokes
how am i doing i am okay i'm okay
i'm all right how about g4
well that was the first reason i said
that we should count
pawns if you go g4 i'd say
we've got five pawns in our opponent
just about a billion just about a
billion billion to five
and we start trading i hedge my bet
on the billions of pawns
is bishop d3 a good idea i don't know if
it's good but it's definitely legal
okay so one of the things of course
you want to activate your rooks but is
there anything else you might want to
activate
fix the f pawn i'm not sure if that's
priority when you're down upon
not not necessarily bad to go f4
but i don't think it's the first thing
that you should be
trying to achieve or do
yeah let's bring that king and that is
exactly
what fisher did not that any of these
moves like rook c7
f4 or bishop d3 is a tragic idea
but why not bring the king when nobody
stops you
also king f2 not only brings the king
it prepares this maneuver of king e to
king d3 and king takes d4
and then practically would be up a king
also between the battle
for the medal now i know there is a bit
of a story that
none of you heard before but if you
can't put a king
a piece or anything in the middle it'll
get boosted
just like in any video games you get
boosted
immediately if you get in the right zone
same in chess you get in there you get
boosted
that's what you want so
that's what fisher is going for even
though i don't think he was
a gamer at all can we quickly evaluate
um i think i can
i don't know if you guys can value it
but if you want to
go ahead what would be your evaluation
right now
how big is the boost oh it's huge it's a
huge boost
it's like a very big one
it's like rooks could fly l-shaped
kind of boost
you're gonna start walking up the king
from now on thanks
yeah uh there is a secret sauce there
that i do have to add
so if it's an end game so
there is a reason why this is called
insane in the endgame probably the end
part
should be caps locked so internet people
could understand
that we are shouting in the end game
so the end part
many people misunderstand and i guess
that's kind of the problem
a lot of people start marching up the
king while it's
the middle game and that's
not that bueno of course
it doesn't ruin your structure but it
does
spoil your game so remember
insane in the end game
insane end game okay are you clear on
that
okay good
so king f2 king g7
rook c7 so now this piggy is
really trying to mess with charis's day
so all right hook c7 rook f7
so we already activated the rook
activated the king is there anything
else we want to activate
you think white is slightly better huh
huh put me down upon though
patrick is saying i hear you saying this
but i find it likely i'll still be going
insane before the end game rule
well that's why you watch all the
episodes of
insane in the end game
so you kind of get in the habit of
learning
over when when you want to become
a little bit loco
i don't know it depends it depends who
you are
all right so you could go bishop d3 or
king e2
um i don't judge whichever you'd like to
do
um
what is better black spawn structure is
so bad
oh so now black should be offered to
resign right
just offer them okay so you have a bad
position your pawns are bad
okay good game resign i don't want to
play this i'll just resign
yeah i never tried that but i
guess i never will so
bishop d3 is a great move but keras
played
i mean karis didn't play anything
because it was fisher's move and fischer
played king e2
king e2 f4 now bishop takes f5
would be a beautiful mistake because
there's bishop takes f5
bishop takes f5 and sadly that rook is
defended
if he would lose so therefore fischer
chose to bring
the king in king e2 f4
inviting fisher to blunder his rook with
bishop f5 oh
condo how kind of him rookie seven
again a rude idea but he is trying to
pick some pawns
like berries okay so
we talked a little bit about the
importance
of the central squares
so if it's important for white is it
important for black
to take control of them control of
them squares
bishop e4 is what you're thinking it's a
good thing
that you thought about bishop e4 but it
is definitely black's move
well yeah we're crying for that a-pawn
we're very very sad but
it is black to move
gypsy does not lose the pawn but it does
lose the other pawn on h7
and with a doubled sag pawns in the
middle
white might just take a walk up to d3
and d4 and it is
bye bye for the black player
now karis still doesn't want to go
bye-bye and he realizes that
oh it's an end game you're supposed to
take control of the middle middle
squares
so king f6 actually b4 makes sense
it's a little bit cheeky again trying to
go for a cheapo
probably not a bad choice but
keras was not in a cheapo mood
king f6 rook takes a6
rookie 7 and now there is
drama on the board which side should we
bring our king
or should we even touch that king
or tell that king to move or not
i mean km6 is a great move he's just
trying to
come closer to those pawns and those
central squares
now just so you guys don't feel too
stressed out the king can go this way
and
that way king d3 is a little bit
suspicious so before anyone says king d3
um yeah i guess it was a bit too late
but anyways don't go king d3 because
that will lose your bishop
so literally you've got two choices
inside clean side
i guess it's the wrong direction so
queen side
king side
king v2 for sure
okay
interestingly enough fisher
goes king f2
yeah bishop e for d5 is not something
you can do in chess
because in a child's or scholastic games
your king would be taken
and that is not something that is very
chest like
that's sort of the way we put it
not very chest-like and we don't like
anything that's not just like
i mean we do like music
check king f2
um king d2 would make sense
but king d2 would leave
our army on the king side sort of loose
and the g pawn would fall
and fisher likes his army being defended
so he goes king f2 and
just notice how fisher plays these
positions
um and the reason why king f2 is played
is because he just wants to make sure
that everything is under control
why not bishop e4 i don't think that
this is necessarily a bad move
it's just troublesome
um in many cultures especially japanese
cultures
there is a saying called mandoksane
which would be roughly translated as
troublesome how shocking now
bishop e4 would be the troublesome kind
of move
is it bad nope is it good
it just feels uncomfortable it's not
that it's
something you cannot do that's something
you
shouldn't do i guess
yeah it kind of boils down to something
that you shouldn't be doing
i hope that explains why fisher didn't
play bishop e4 here
it's just mandaxane so he goes king f2
instead
it says nah just defend everything
and see what my esteemed estonian
player is thinking about this position
how uncomfortable um i don't know how
uncomfortable
because i'm not bobby fisher he probably
would tell you how uncomfortable
although talking about uncomfortable
possibly your bishop wouldn't feel too
comfortable after d5
as it would get trapped in the middle of
the board i guess
that's the reason possibly
f2 bishop e6
rook takes d6 king e5 brook c6
fischer's only 16 here i'm pretty sure
he would have a strong opinion of bishop
e4 still
rook c6 bishop d5
okay so there's always a moment
of uncertainty when you're not sure how
many pawns you have
so i would get a bit uncertain and do
the yasser thing
counting pawns i would go
one two three four five for
us for black
not as many i wouldn't go not as many
but
probably i'd say four so
i guess things are looking good
all right when things are looking good
what are you supposed to do
chat viewers lurkers
what are we supposed to do when things
are
looking groovy
win no no we never win
we just wait for our opponent to resign
maintain the position
moves that doesn't sound like evaluation
to me
if things are looking groovy we look for
a wind
okay improve that position
anatoly karpov
yeah yeah that that's fair
um positional advantages want to be
nurtured okay so if we're
against nature but we want to nurture
the advantage
how can we nurture that advantage
where would be the main spot that we
would like to
give a little bit of a massage
yes yasser would put it
exchange but right now the first thing
that we've got to deal with that our
rock is under attack
so never forget your opponent's first
thought is
ha ha somehow i'm going to be like a
snake in a grass and i'm going to take
your pieces
so you've got to be vigilant not to
blunder
in one i'm just telling you upfront
don't hang your rock
if we trade pieces it's a winning
endgame
that is correct because we've got an
extra pawn
pressure the b-pawn how matt wilson how
should we attack that b-pawn
so we've got some people who love rk6
some people who want to pester the
b-pawn
but i'm still not sure which way we've
got a rook c5
idea got a rook b6 idea
okay um
how do grandmasters know which square to
move to
so i assume that fisher looked at
all three of these options and said well
there is a higher probability
that if i attack x y z pawn
there's a like likelier chance i'm going
to succeed
now i'm not sure if he used the word
probability it's something i'm
i'm rephrasing his thoughts let's put it
that way
i do think that chess players
have this internal statistical machine
that's always working and they go
okay okay this this is an idea
but it's not just doesn't feel right
statistically
the advantage is just insignificant
and it just doesn't fit my hypothesis
of course this is a language used by
0.0005
of the grand masters i've ever met
so probably not many
anyways here fisher ran for rook h6
because he thought statistically this
pawn should be falling now
rook c4 like rook v6 is very interesting
rook c5
there might be king d6 takes bishop c4
and there is a famous saying you should
have
quality pieces and not a high quantity
of
pawns high quantity of pawns so you
should have
better improved pieces over there and
not just
terrible ones on b1 and talking about
terrible ones on b1
after this naughty check we can go king
c5
say hello to that rook and after rookie
to check
rookie one we can say bon voyage
for that bishop so if you go here
here here check
king f2 is not advised because it's mate
and if you go here i take here now you
might be telling me that you can't take
that pawn
but again quality over quantity
that d-pawn is going to make a run for
it and probably
it is black who will be pushing
neural nets are the future
nah they're the past anyways moving on
to more important topics rook
age 6 was played because
a smart human being decided that rook 86
is probably the most practical move and
by the way
talking about good practical decisions
there's like this thing something that
sort of distinguishes humans
and androids that kind of
think of electric sheep or dream of
electric shape rather
now fisher
was a prototype computer thinker
like he always thought like a computer
he wasn't really trying
to make the ultimate best move but that
the one that preserves the advantage so
maybe rook h6
isn't the best one but limits
keras chances of survival
and that's actually one of those
disagreements that computers have
and professional chess players have
which is not quite true because those
who actually create these computers and
ais
they're not super grandmasters
themselves i'm sorry to say that
um otherwise they wouldn't get this
ludicrous ratings of
34k which is a rating
i don't know who invented that thought
that definitely
they didn't they might be 2 900. 34k
no way no way that's that's
not not a thing anyways my point is
sometimes um computers say well
hey hey that was a bad move that move
that you played there
up five queens was a terrible move
but humans we don't really count queens
because unlike computers we know
that at the end of the day if i
checkmate they're still just going to
give you one
zero so if i get one
zero if i'm up just a rook but i'm
mating you that's good enough for me so
that's one of those things
that fisher was really good at
he went for the minimum amount of
advantage but he know he's going to
nurse it
to victory now i think i added an extra
zero over there
that's not what i intended to do
yeah let's stick with to 34 million
we can't go wrong with that one all
right so rook h6
now if we're trying to understand end
games
and we just talked about quality over
quantity
what is something that polkas should
look for in this position
easiest path to victory rather than the
quickest right again the clock is a
factor
yeah when anything or everything is
online
we know the only thing that matters is
the clock
there is actually one specific streamer
uh who i was sort of joking with and
said
well if they ever do a scientific
experiment with you
they're going to think that oh the clock
must be the most important thing in
chess
but they would not realize that
her method is just to use the clock
as a weapon which is actually
completely fair and probably time
trouble was a factor in this game as
well
anyways so we're looking for
a clever and aggressive move by paul
cares which
actually will make bobby's life a little
harder
probably fisher hadn't reached the other
night on g4
he wasn't really a dreamer he was a
technician
how do we improve at endgames well you
try to
guess the move for paul karas
i actually gave you a beautiful hint
which is
quality over quantity
that there's a pawn hanging there but
if you're sort of
thinking about this position outlaw and
say quality over quantity
what could borosh mean by that what
could he mean
sensei borosh might have something that
he really wants to tell you with that
one
well yeah he wanted to because rook c7
and
what paul carris is doing saying hey hey
you can take my pawn
i don't care have my pawn i will
infiltrate and will get a very
aggressive
rook over there with bishop c4
just to demonstrate
this actually looks somewhat dangerous
enough for
black because of the active pieces
so something that people misunderstand
everyone starts counting
pawns and pieces like crazy when they
get into the end game
and they sort of forget that it's still
the quality of your pieces that count
so here fischer said okay i know what
you want so i'm going to give a check
king d6 check again king e5
check again king d6 rook h6 check
they agreed to a draw and fisher
qualified for the knockout phase of the
magnus invitational
i mean if they would have a magnus
invitational for the zurich event in
1959
but fortunately or unfortunately
whichever way you look at it
he didn't have a qualifying spot on the
line so
he didn't go for rook h6 check
shocking right who would have thought
she met rook five saying oh you know
what i am going to do
what carlson will do
years and years and years and years
later
fight till the last second so
saying okay if you want to activate your
pieces
be my guest i don't mind at all
i don't mind at all c1 bishop d3
rook d1 king e2 rook g1
all right so again
bobby sort of tried to test whether this
is really not the magnus invitational
so he actually did one repetition and
said okay
can you have two maybe this is the
magnus invitational already just have to
have to test it for a couple more moves
let's see not c
okay king f2 rook d1 king e2 it seems to
be working
ah no it yeah news came in
nope not the magnus invitational yet
so yeah um king f2 still would qualify
because rook g5
blunder continuing on to play in the
position
why would you do that why would you want
to win this game
yes tough tough tough stuff
yeah rook g5 so what he's trying to do
actually was trying to gain some time
and this is one of those things that
they did
uh in those olden ages they would do a
couple of repetitions
so they wouldn't flag they were move 40
move 50 rules plenty of these
rules of an amount that you've got to
reach
move 40 you reach it
good you've got an extra hour to
find your ideas ship takes a2
bishop takes b5 all right
rogue b1 so it seems that
fisher did the right thing he's up a
pawn
and as far as i can count he still
in the driver's seat however as more i
look at that b-pawn
it seems rather doomed so if that b-pawn
is a little doomed what can we do
what can we do if one of our pawns are
doomed
and we can't do nothing about it
we do these in online games with
increment all the time
or at least i do no that's a good thing
it's good it's a good method
to actually gain time but
be careful not to fall into the
three-fold repetition
all right so in chance you've got to
suggest
moves of course it's good to theorize
build hypothesis
and uh ideas like that but
at the end of the day you need to play
some moves and ideas
yep here fisher goes
after the d-pawn quickly
immediately takes check takes king takes
d4
rook takes check king e7 and look at
that
perseverance did pay dividends
for bobby he's up a pawn
but there are some dangers
and those are those things that you
shouldn't forget when you have a better
positions you have to identify the
dangers you're facing
what danger is white facing in this type
of position
and this is again like i know i know i
jump from being hypothetical
to being very concrete but sometimes
you've got to do that
especially when there's such a limited
amount of material on the board
what is some certain trick that black
can aim for
only three pawns left on the board
what would happen if those pawns would
whoosh
disappear
the wrong corner
i mean wrong corner is one idea that is
definitely an idea kokonov of course
well if those pawns would disappear then
we would have an
end game even if black would lose the
bishop but would
pick up and take those white squared
pawns
it would still be a theoretical draw
so fisher will be able
and will have to be careful about not to
fall for that
king e4 rook here bishop a6
ship f7 so it's just making sure that
that bishop
won't be attacked and again notice
everything
on this side of the board as well defend
it
bishop c8 g6 rook h7
bishop g4 and this is actually masterful
technique
by fisher the computers might not agree
that this is the best but from a
practical standpoint
this is fantastic why well he just makes
sure everything's under control
and then he proceeds to move forward
from there
rook g7 here take stakes
king takes f4 okay so this is a little
bit tricky
we are reaching the end part
of the end game so that's the very very
very
end part of the game
so there's only one more thing that
we've got to be careful with right
not to lose the f pawn because if we do
that's the wrong corner and really
nobody cares that we have an extra
bishop
that is still a draw but fisher is
vigilant king g5 f4
bishop e4 f5 would be
kind of move because we should have five
and the king would chasse
back and forth so that's no good h4
h5 h6 bishop f5
not a trade that keras would like to
take
bishop g6 should be 6 here
just a little bit of shuffling there's
no reason for fischer to rush
bishop g4 this is still a win
if black takes king takes here king f5
and we get what we all love in chess and
that's called the opposition
here we would even control the
all-important f8 square and we are
winning
so it goes bishop c4 f5 should page h5
here
in f6 and here
keras resigned but
you still got to be careful not to mess
it up
completely and the main plan that
uh wins here is to bring that king to e7
do nothing spectacular because black is
just uh
condemned to waiting so we just go here
bring the king over
wait for the right moment and like a
hawk
strike with bishop e6 no more
controlling of those squares
you've got to leave f7
and we promote to a queen and
winning also if bishop g8
we still have this idea so instead of
bishop b3 bishop e6
now we exchange there's no way you can
control that square anymore
f7 looks like a stalemate
seems like a stalemate not quite the
stalemate
because we're gonna queen and win the
game so that is the reason
why in this position after f6
bobby fischer won the game and paul
karas design
so thank you so much for watching hope
you enjoyed
this lesson of the game between fisher
and paul karas
[Music]
you